[Musique]
qui veut commencer valérie bella et
malice série dont quelques interviews
tu as dit que tu avais à peu près déjà
programmé la fin de touche pas à mon
poste et que tu envisages et
éventuellement les l'avenir est ce que
tu es toujours sur cette période de dire
que dans aller 2 3 ans maximum ses pmp
c'est fini pour toi et pour nous alors
franchement aurait pour l'instant je
suis dans ce truc là où elle doit tenir
dans deux trois ans tpm fait c'est fini
pour moi après c'est pas sûr que tpm
paix soit finie puisque je pense que tpm
peut avoir une vie sans moi mais il est
très possible que j'arrête tu es passé
oui ma vie non encore deux trois enfants
c'est pas vrai folie donc c'est sûr aimé
j'espère que tpm paix continuera
vraiment gilles cyril vous devez virer
définitivement un des chroniqueurs
présents de là à cette très bonne
question direz vous
ouais c'est à dire je suis obligé sinon
est quelqu'un de ma famille qui m'a
obligé à elles prennent de la vérité je
vire
maj il c'est celui qui dit qui y est
[Applaudissements]
franchement je leur dirai un
obligatoirement oui bah oui bah oui
franchement je je vire mathieu mais non
pardon je vais vous dire pourquoi je
vous dire pourquoi ils cherchent la paix
c'est celui qui m'a mis la plus mauvaise
note au conseil c'est sûr michelle
[Applaudissements]
filteau conseil de classe
merci jean mathieu dramé répond pour de
vrai pour de vrai franchement je dois en
virée 1 je vais virer celui qui me coûte
le plus cher
mais mathieu benjamin benjamin questions
sur vrai parce que moi je peux rentrer
du boulot derrière elisabeth
vous savez ils ont tous on dit tout à
l'heure que quand vous aimiez vous
ignoriez de textos et d'appels le
week-end moi je ne reçois jamais rien
j'en tire les conséquences
oui oh non ça veut rien dire il n'y a
pas de question c'est toi jean tirer les
conséquences que vous l'aimez frais non
mais vous ne répondez jamais au
téléphone
c'est vrai je vous jure que c'est vrai
ne répond jamais au téléphone alors je
tombe sur son répondeur
ok insupportable je vous le dis son
répondeur est insupportable et je ne
veux pas tomber sur votre répondeur ce
que vous allez je vous appelle pour
qu'on écoute votre répondeur
oui il est tellement relou sur les
fraudeurs mais je ne peux pas le voir je
vous le faire écouter
c'est un point commun avec ma mère alors
est ce que voulait alors dû au non mais
il faut jure
regardez je vais l'appeler il est
insupportable son répondeur donc il
faudrait que vous ne répondez jamais
doko donc forcément je ne vous appelle
pas alors que les hôtes et nora mathieu
texto que on reconnaît là enfin mon avis
la tension que nous portent serré qui a
dans le texto regardez regardez
j'appelle isabelle vrai débat c'est
écoutez bien sonné ça mais c'est de
regarder comme lé rôle répondait pas
[Musique]
ma maman
[Applaudissements]
on comprend mieux la c'est mon kiné
c'est un jour où j'enregistrais de
message vocal comme le kiné mon kiné mon
meilleur ami se sont amusés à polluer
les messages et les eaux l'air très
sympa les questions aux capucines moi
c'est une question que j'ai envie de
vous poser pour de vrai depuis que je
suis arrivé pour les autres ce pur de
fonds maintient à coeur en fête depuis
arrivées mathieu ne cesse de me répéter
tous les week-ends en bouquet tout ça
que si je suis là c'est uniquement grâce
à lui par son possible m'a proposé
arrête de mentir tunis et moi qui t'ai
proposa série née et a pris grâce à moi
j'ai aimé qu'elle est vraie ou pas que
vous m'avez pris parce que mathieu vous
a dit de me prendre
alors je vais vous dire belmont vraiment
mais arrête on n'a pas arrêté arrêté
vous êtes un menteur je vous le dis
capucine
jamais de la vie je n'ai même pas
demandé l'avis de mathieu mathieu ne m'a
jamais demandé de vous prendre
merci je pense qu'il a pris je vous
prenez après qu'on ait signé donc voilà
donc mathieu n'était même pas au courant
exactement vous directement la musique
au jard hiver vous mathieu donnant les
deux vous allez devenir inaudible
heureusement qu il ya un problème
terrible
des invités un invité que vous avez
regretté d'avoir fait venir vraiment en
toute sincérité quelqu'un qui est venu
et une fois qu'il est sorti du plateau
après l'émission vous animez pourquoi je
les invite et c'était une panne à ce
voyage
françois joly alors elle c'est un mec en
plus que j'aime bien mais j'aimais
beaucoup ce mec là est le dernier invité
où je me suis dit ça je vous dis la
vérité ça mais qu'en plus vraiment je
les aime beaucoup c'est un pote et j'ai
pas compris que dans l'émission il était
hyper rollon c'est vincent elbaz est
mérité quand il a dit je comprends pas
on est en direct
donc ils avaient paru marquer il n'avait
pas regardé l'émission donc voilà je
vais trouver un peu relou lors de
l'émission de bons jeunes doit quand
même
voilà donc oui je vous dis franchement
j'avais vu ses ventes annuelles
c'est que vous avez eu une période où
vous étiez un peu au fond du trou
qu'est-ce que vous avez alkali de cette
période
c'est vrai que non mais sérieusement
vous allez voir menasria difficile
qu'est ce que vous allez a pris 2,7 en
mai la chasse et oui mais ça c'est ça
c'est rien ça j'ai appris j'ai appris
quoi avec les mairies va fermer ma
gueule alors qui est laura vous à un
moment vous avez pris beaucoup beaucoup
et toujours des critiques un peu dans la
gueule quelle est celle qui vous a le
plus blessé parmi tout ce que vous avez
pu lire ou entendre aucune vraiment
fière que les critiques des
téléspectateurs qui me blessent ou les
français que je lis à peu près tous les
tweets je lis tous les trucs parce
qu'elles sont souvent très constructive
et l'hymne de rien et je modifie
l'émission par rapport à ce que me
disent les gens sur twitter après
vraiment ce qui peut être dit dans la
presse vraiment et vous le savez ici 10
ans ça me passe complètement au dessus
je m'en fous totalement nous allons
danser les gens ce qui vaut blaise ouais
en fout totalement qui vous blesse
vraiment je crois c'est les critiques
contre nous la vraie réagissez lycée va
lui en hausse outre-rhin
parce que parce que je vous donnais je
veux dire que je vous dis toute la
vérité c'est vrai qu'il y en a parfois
qu'ils sont très touché par les
critiques qui s'arrêtent à chaque fois
je leur dis voilà je m'occupe plus deux
mais franchement moi je m'en fous
totalement vraiment et vous le voyez
vous le savez madame a dit monsieur est
ce que vous pensez qu'il était judicieux
de me faire venir sur ce prime tpm paix
toute la vérité alors que personne ne me
connaît sait d'oranger ou dire oui je
vous dire pourquoi parce que c'est
toujours bien d'avoir une bonne meuf
autour de la table en fête j'allais pas
vous dire de partir ça se faisait pas
moi quand j'invite les gens à la maison
eh bien il reste jusqu'à la fin de
l'année voilà vous le dis donc voilà et
ben voilà donc on écoute beaucoup
ouais d'où le pij pourquoi c'est ça
parce que vous êtes vous regrettez pas
du tout c'était une question je me
posais sincèrement et donc je voulais
poser tout aussi sincèrement merci va
très bien alors qui est encore une
question à prendre vous aimez bien les
défis la compétition vous êtes un
gagnant d'accord vous êtes reconnu peu à
peu près tout le monde comme dans au top
du paf
est-ce que vous n'êtes ni en tête à
nouveau défi jean est dans le métier de
patron de chaîne ou quelque chose qui
soit aux tenues au dessus d'animateur
bafa 1,37 ça vous plairait vous l'avez
toujours dit franchement ça valait
officiellement l'air énorme ça me
plairait après laure moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est franchement j'aimerais
partir dans le sport après pour ça que
j'ai fini a dirigé le psg
on m'a souvent dit que je ressemble à
nasser lalaoui voilà on va partir dans
le sport après ce serait qu'on a envie
de partir dans le sport à la fère ont
peut-être des émissions autour du sport
ou peut-être dirigiez ou acheter un club
ouais bah ça serait mon rêve assurément
si un jour je pouvais acheter le long
avant guingamp serait comme un non mais
je rigole pas c'est vraiment bon répond
non mais je vous le dis c'est mon rêve
oui alors je n'ai de la première heure
ce sera les dernières c'est bon bref
vous ouais la première plus légère si
elle vous appelez qu'elle vous demandait
de revenir trois fois par semaine dans
l'émission à partir la semaine prochaine
est ce que vous êtes septoriose avila
oui trois fois par semaine oui ok vous
accepterez nabila j'enlèverai juste les
couteaux en loge mais sinon oui voila je
le dis franchement oui
question un peu plus perso que ce soit
justifié ou injustifiées est ce que vous
regrettez parfois lorsque vous êtes un
petit peu en colère après quelqu'un en
l'occurence un des chroniqueurs de nous
appeler à chaud et de ne pas laisser
retomber un tout petit peu la pression
avant d'avoir nous dire ce que vous avez
à vous dire ce qui est parfois dit du
coup avec un petit peu de un petit peu
de temps merci de devises de véhémence
et ce qui est pas toujours très agréable
pour nous c'est pour ça qu'ils vous dire
je suis comme edith piaf je ne
regretterai non mais non non non
franchement non
parce qu'on est des potes et moi je pars
du principe qu'on doit tous se dit
franchement c'est vrai et je vais pas
prendre des pincettes avec vous abbas
je prendrai des pincettes avec vous
c'est qu'on est plus pop et c'est qu'il
ya un vrai problème
le jour où je vous appellerai plus c'est
qu'il ya un vrai problème joli et
franchement je préfère dire les choses
si rim connaît depuis de nombreuses
années je dis toujours les choses mais
je ne fais jamais de coups par derrière
et le sait vraiment jamais je ne ferai
jamais c'est pas
pas du tout oui ce qu'elle stresse ans
il vous dit que les choses à chaud mais
vous ça retombe très vite donc après
vous redevenez comme avant et vous
n'êtes pas en cumulé ça qu on passe vite
l'eponge en anglais et puis deux jours
après j'ai [ __ ] il va me faire la
gueule mais j'arrivais sérieux comme un
jour mais comment tu vas que ces tracés
oublier quand même un point d'ici là il
n'a pas donné on est à inventer les
potes aller voilà je suis à paris je
vous dirai toujours les choses et quand
je vous dis des trucs c'est d'abord pour
le bien de l'émission je vous jure que
c'est vrai et franchement je dis
rarement des choses pour vous blessez
gratuitement bras